- Yo, this is your
G girl from Norway.
This song goes out
to all you guys
singing about
disrespecting women.
You think you're a tough dude?
Go pick on someone
your own size.
Or man up, and pick on
someone even bigger than you.
You know what I sing about?
I sing about
disrespecting mountains.
Yeah, that's right.
Check it out.
Whoa, here we go.
♪ Sexist songs, too
many I'm countin'
♪ Instead, I'm
disrespectin' mountains
♪ They're bigger than me,
but there ain't no doubtin'
♪ Oi, oi, I'm
disrespectin' mountains
♪ Kick a stone, kick a branch
♪ Kick a pile of leaves
♪ I'll piss in the river
♪ I hope that they see
♪ That there's a
river and it says
♪ You cannot cross me
♪ I just crossed your bridge
♪ You're not the boss of me
♪ If you decide to
freeze or take my skis
♪ I'll go down on you
♪ Slalom right
between your trees
♪ I leave out my garbage
♪ Just kidding, who would
ever do that fucked up shit
♪ Yeah, that's right
♪ 'Cause garbage
rhymes with shit
(snaps)
♪ They're bigger than me,
but there ain't no doubtin'
♪ Oi, oi, I'm
disrespectin' mountains
♪ They're bigger than me,
but there ain't no doubtin'
♪ Oi, oi, I'm
disrespectin' mountains
♪ If you're still singing
about disrespecting women
♪ You're so behind on the times
♪ You shouldn't even be livin'
♪ Hey, yeah, rapper dude
♪ I've got a bone to pick
♪ Let's see how tough
you are when you suck my
♪ Mountain cliff
♪ I climb a tree,
I dominate the tree
♪ I cut the tree down
for his friends to see
♪ And while you're a child
still rappin' about asses
♪ I make fire with logs
and I leave those ashes
♪ Ba duh duh ba
duh ba duh ba duh
♪ Asses
♪ That's right, I'm
a mean ass mo fucker
♪ And when I say mo fucker,
I mean mountain fucker
♪ 'Cause I've got real
respect for all those mothers
♪ But not those mo
fo mountain fuckers
♪ They're bigger than me,
but there ain't no doubtin'
♪ Oi, oi, I'm
disrespectin' mountains
♪ They're bigger than me,
but there ain't no doubtin'
♪ Oi, oi, I'm
disrespectin' mountains ♪
If you've been affected
by today's music song,
you can help donate to
your local tree factory.
Help stop global warming.
Save our mountains.
By helping protect
our environment,
we protect our world.
Thank you, and
goodbye from Norway.
Drop the mic.